I just wanted to address your concerns
about my body there are many different
kinds of beautiful there are many
different ways to look healthy Ariana
Grande getting real with fans I wanna
be myself but also like what comes with
that is crazy the singer addresses
recent online comments about her body on
Tick Tock I know personally for me the
body that you've been comparing my
current body to
was the unhealthiest version of my body
I was on a lot of antidepressants and
drinking on them and eating poorly and
at the lowest point of my life when I
looked the way you consider my healthy
but that in fact wasn't my healthy
Ariana points out that she knows the
concerns are out of care but lets her
followers know to be mindful of those
opinions I think we should be gentler
and less comfortable commenting on
people's bodies no matter what if you
think you're saying something good or
well-intentioned whatever it is healthy
unhealthy big small this that sexy not
sexy I I don't there are ways to
compliment someone or
to ignore something that you see that
you don't like that I think we should
help each other work towards the star
goes on to outline reasons why spreading
love is always the better choice there
are many different kinds of beautiful
that's the first thing
healthy can look different the second
thing is you never know what someone is
going through so even if you are coming
from a loving place in a Caring Place
that person probably is working on it or
has a support system that they are
working on it with and the third one's
unrelated I guess I just wanted to
extend some love your way and tell you
that you're beautiful no matter what
phase you're in while Ari believes she
shouldn't have to explain this she hopes
her vulnerability leads to a bigger
conversation just to aim towards
being safer and keeping each other safer
Ariana's currently filming Wicked the
film adaptation of the Broadway musical
starring as Glinda the Good Witch the
role made Popular by Kristen Chenoweth
Popular
you're gonna be popular I've known
Ariana Grande since she was 10. so
Ariana I'm very very proud of you she
knows we talk every day I love you baby
girl and it's an honor and a pleasure to
pass the wand and the crown to you
alongside Ariana Cynthia arrivo playing
Elphaba the Wicked Witch of the West the
both of us are working really really
hard and we're trying to bring you
something that you might not expect it's
not going to vary too far away hopefully
from the stage but I think you'll get
more from it now I think you'll get more
of the story of the two of these
wonderful characters who have lots of
life to give yeah fans can look forward
to the Remake set to come out in two
installments arriving in November 2024
and December
2025. it's a very exciting thing for us
[Music]
thank you